everyone welcome to the Allen P Kirby
jr. center for constitutional studies
and citizenship where we are the outpost
for Hillsdale College here in our
nation's capital as many of you know we
host numerous educational programs and
the liberal arts tradition and on the
first principles of our country so as is
our tradition we were going to have one
of our students introduce our special
guest for this evening
Reagan cool is a junior studying
political philosophy and religion and is
originally from Grand Rapids Michigan
this semester she's interning at the
American principles project while
studying on the Washington Hillsdale
internship program here in DC Reagan
good evening tonight I have the pleasure
of introducing Miss Heather McDonald
Heather McDonald is the Thomas W Smith
fellow at the Manhattan Institute and a
contributing editor of city journal
she earned a Bachelor of Arts in English
from Yale University a Master of Arts in
English at Cambridge University and a
Juris Doctor degree from Stanford Law
School she writes for several newspapers
and periodicals including The Wall
Street Journal the New York Times and
Public Interest she's also the author of
several books including the war on cops
and the burden of bad ideas tonight she
will discuss her latest publication the
diversity delusion how race and gender
pandering corrupt the University and
undermine our culture please join me in
extending a warm welcome to miss Heather
McDonald
thank you so much I mean I've been on
the road get my little secret water
glass here before I start I don't have a
cough attack thank you so much thank you
Regan and thank you for Hillsdale this
is get back to normalcy I've been I've
been speaking a lot on college campuses
recently you know what that means I've
received the walk out the storm the
stage strategy and at Claremont McKenna
College in California the blockade which
prevented anyone from actually entering
to hear my talk so-called students of
color at nearby Pomona College announced
that I was a quote fascist white
supremacist Warhawk trans folk queer
folk lacist and ignorant of ignorance
ystem zuv domination that produced the
lethal conditions under which oppressed
peoples are forced to live end quote so
to actually have an audience still in
its seats and apparently willing to
listen is an unusual experience outside
of a Hillsdale crowd that may take me a
few minutes to adjust to now we've been
hearing a lot of late about the crisis
of free speech on college campuses but
not much about its root cause the
narcissistic victimology that is rapidly
spreading from academia to the rest of
our culture in a word the American
University and again all of this applies
to everything other than Hillsdale
fortunately so we can at least remember
there's some sanity left but in general
the American University is in the grips
of a mass hysteria students actually
believe that they are victims of
oppression at risk of their lives from
circumambulate ISM and sexism the degree
of maudlin caterwauling is impossible to
overstate at Brown students of color
occupied the president's office and
complained about having to meet such
academic expectations
as going to the class when they were so
focused on quote staying alive and Brown
at Yale a mob of minority students
surrounded a highly respected
sociologist and cursed and screamed at
him for three hours because his wife had
sent an email suggesting that students
can choose their own Halloween costumes
free from the ministrations of Yale's
diversity bureaucrats among the shouts
of shut the eff up and you are
disgusting that were directed at this
mild-mannered left-wing professor was a
cry of or dying from one of the ranters
referring to the allegedly endangered
status of Yale's minority students but
my favorite moment in this parade of
narcissism comes from Princeton in 2015
Princeton's black students chanted were
sick and tired of being sick and tired
now this was a phrase first used by
fannie lou hamer a civil rights activist
who was beaten in the 1950s for trying
to vote fannie lou hamer
had grounds of Plenty for being sick and
tired of being sick and tired but any
Princeton student I don't care if he's
purple orange or blue who thinks of
himself as oppressed is in the grip of a
terrible delusion that will encumber him
for the rest of his life
well perhaps you're thinking at least
the adults on campus are trying to give
these students a firmer grip of reality
to the contrary the adults actively
encourage this hysteria a massive
diversity bureaucracy is devoted to
cultivating in students ever more arcane
species of self involvement and ever
more preposterous forms of self-pity you
want to know the reason for astronomical
tuition look no further than this
bureaucratic bloat students regularly
act out little psychodramas of
oppression before an appreciative
audience of diversity Dean Lutz and vice
Provo
of equity and inclusion who used the
occasion to expand their Dominion many
campuses have created bias response
teams modeled presumably on active
shooter response teams on the assumption
that discrimination is so rampant and
lethal on campus that a rapid defense
forces needed freshman orientations and
dorm sessions invariably features
seminars on toxic masculinity and white
privilege students are taught that they
are either the oppressed or the
oppressors if you are not female black
Hispanic gay or any one of the 116 and
still metastasizing categories of gender
the only way that you can escape being
an oppressor is by becoming a quote ally
allies are something usually associated
with war and indeed the reigning
thinking is that female students and
students of color are literally in a war
zone on college campuses and need allies
from the opposing side to survive am i
exaggerating I am NOT UC Berkeley's
division of equity and inclusion hung
banners throughout campus reminding
students of the University of
California's paramount mission assigning
guilt and innocence in the ruthlessly
competitive totem pole of victimhood one
banner banner featured a female black
student and a male Hispanic student
allegedly pleading allow people other
than yourself to exist a message
directed to Berkeley's white students
and faculty this is not hyperbole they
meant it literally college presidents
are the worst offenders in encouraging
this delusional victimology
after the three-hour expletive filled
tirade against the Yale sociologist
yells president Peter Salovey actually
thanked the boorish thugs for making him
proud of his student body
Yale subsequently conferred a race
justice prize on two of the most
aggressive participants the Dean of the
Harvard Medical School recently removed
the portraits of its greatest physician
scientists from the entrance hall to the
school you can guess the reason they
were all male and thus looking on them
would make Harvard's wilting medical
students feel uncomfortable and unsafe
we can only wish these budding doctors
luck in the operating room
narcissistic identity politics has
destroyed the serious pursuit of
knowledge throughout the humanities and
most of the social sciences students are
being given a license for ignorance all
they need to be told about a book is the
melanin content and gonads of its author
to know whether they can dismiss its
contents as thoroughly repugnant and not
worth reading Shakespeare Milton Plato
condon Locke have been variously
defenestrated by students who have not
the slightest clue about Periclean
Athens the Renaissance or the
Enlightenment a Columbia undergraduate
groused about Columbia's beleaguered
core curriculum quote who is this Mozart
this Hyden these superior white men the
core she said upholds the premises of
white supremacy and racism no professor
has ever defended our intellectual
patrimony against such shameful
outbreaks of ecstatic no nothing ism
without appending some pooling
qualification about respect for
diversity academic identity politics are
now rapidly spreading throughout the
culture at large every non academic
institution no matter how previously
meritocratic is now vulnerable and that
means above all the STEM fields Exhibit
A into our culture's descent into
identity driven mediocrity and thought
control is the firing of computer
engineer James d'amour from Google in
August 2017 d'amour had written a
carefully reasoned fact-based memo
suggesting that the average career
preferences of males and females may
explain why there's not 50/50 gender
parity at Google and other tech firms
the language that Google's CEO used in
firing mr. d'amour
was a direct import from academic
victimology Google's employees were
quote hurting
he said because d'amour had dared to
challenge the reigning feminist
orthodoxy what followed mr. De Morris
firing was even scarier a regional
branch of the National Labor Relations
Board upheld Google's actions on the
same basis drenched victim grounds mr.
d'amours memo had made Google's
employees feel quote unsafe at work
according to the NLRB associate general
counsel the memo thus constituted quote
discrimination and sexual harassment
consider for a moment what this NLRB
ruling means for science any
evolutionary biologist soaked
psychologist or account economist who
studies the different risk preferences
and appetite for competition among males
and females is now at risk of his job
these branches of shut of science could
shut down completely no matter that
their findings are true the thinking
that got mr. d'amour fired is now the
dominant characteristic of our time it
holds that the absence of exact
proportional representation of various
racial ethnic and sexual groups in any
institution is by definition a result of
discrimination to suggest that different
groups have different capacities
cultures skills and behaviors that
explain the lack of proportional
representation is not just taboo it can
get you fired
and so the mad rage for race and gender
proportionality in the workplace is
accelerating especially in the me to
moment from here on out everything you
read everything you watch
in the mainstream media will have been
calculated in conformity with the
demands of diversity if you are a white
male no matter how talented you're gonna
have to meet a higher standard to get
hired or promoted this summer California
Polytechnic Institute's crusade to lower
the number of whites on campus with
succeeding
every college is in essence doing the
same thing if not as publicly newsrooms
are under enormous pressure to find
reporters select sources and originate
stories that improve their diversity
profile book publishers are obsessively
engineering their lists to prioritize
quote diverse authors and themes thanks
to media pressure and their own human
resources departments corporate
boardrooms have made a fetish of gender
proportionality even before California
mandated female board hires I routinely
voted against every female who shows up
on a proxy ballot since I assume that
she is there because of her sex and not
her business experience a case in point
drew Gilpin Faust the outgoing president
of Harvard recently accepted a position
on the board of Goldman Sachs now who
knew that left-wing history professors
were experts in Investment Banking
university administrators and faculty
may hate capitalism but they love
capitalist dollars even classical music
is being poisoned by identity politics
New Yorker music critic Alex Ross
triggered outrage against the Chicago
and Philadelphia Symphony Orchestra's
this spring by tweeting that they had
programmed no female composers in their
upcoming seasons
never mind that at that very moment the
Chicago Symphony was at Carnegie Hall
performing Jennifer higden's concerto
for low brass a work commissioned by the
Chicago and Philadelphia orchestras at
doubt greatly inflated cost it is absurd
to expect gender parity in the concert
hall the reality is this the greatest
composers of all time whether Bach
Mozart Beethoven Schubert Chopin or
Brahms were male get over it and simply
be grateful for the beauty that they
gave us unworthy mortals but classical
music boards are also under enormous
pressure to hire by gender and race for
conducting positions and everything else
a classical music music agent told me
wistfully quote if only I had a trans
conductor I'd be rich now it is an
unalloyed pleasure that Hollywood is
being forced to sacrifice its best
box-office judgements to meet the
demands of the race and gender
bean-counters but it is in the sciences
where the diversity imperative becomes
actually dangerous every academic
science department whether physics
mathematics or chemistry is in the
victimology crosshairs
the federal government is demanding that
scientific departments hire based on
gender and race rather than scientific
merit science education is being slowed
down and watered down in the hope of
graduating more females and
underrepresented minorities an
oncologist in an Ivy Lee at an Ivy
League medical school was berated by his
Dean for an exam in pharmacology that
was quote too fact-based well I don't
know about you but if I have cancer
I want my doctor to know the facts about
drug interactions the National Science
Foundation is spending billions of your
taxpayer dollars on programs to boost
diversity in science arguing that only a
diverse laboratory can achieve
scientific breakthroughs well that's
funny because somehow the 200 now
Science Foundation grantees who won
Nobel Prizes managed to discover dark
matter and the genetics of viruses among
other breakthroughs without conforming
to today's diversity metrics and of
course this mania for gender and race
parity and science continues into the
private sector after James d'amour was
fired a human resources manager sued
YouTube and Google for firing him
because he had refused to go along with
the mandate to interview only females
and underrepresented minorities for
incoming engineering jobs potentially
groundbreaking scientists are being
passed over today because they are of
the wrong race and gender guess who does
not care about diversity China the best
thing that trump could do to level the
playing field would be to airlift a few
cargo planes of gender theorists from
American universities and dump them on
Beijing University and China's research
labs until that happens China will
inexorably pull out ahead of us since in
science it cares only about one thing
scientific achievement academic identity
politics is tearing our society apart it
is teaching young people to hate to hate
the greatest thinkers and creators of
the past and to hate their fellow
Americans the diversity delusion
therefore has to be nipped in the bud
the next time self engrossed students
occupy a campus building demanding
reparations here is what their college
president should say are you kidding me
you're the most privileged individuals
in human history you have at your
fingertips the thing that Faust sold his
soul for knowledge you're surrounded by
libraries that would have driven the
Renaissance humanists wild with envy and
desire you can read any book that has
ever been written you have access to
scientific laboratories that are the
most advanced in the world you can
pursue languages literature and history
everything is available far from
discriminating against minorities and
females in hiring every faculty search
here is one desperate effort at finding
remotely qualified underrepresented
minority and female candidates who have
not already been scooped up by better
endowed schools far from discriminating
against underrepresented minorities and
admissions we employ double standards in
order to engineer so-called diversity I
can assure you that my faculty are not
bigots they have nothing but good will
for history's oppressed groups and want
all their students to succeed at this
very moment millions of Asian students
abroad are studying night and day for
the privilege of experiencing this
alleged maelstrom of hatred if you feel
so oppressed step aside and let them
take your place but a college president
never says any of these things of course
instead he is silent before these
outbreaks of narcissistic delusion happy
to sell out his faculty as alleged
racists and penitently promising to make
further amends for so mistreating the
oppressed students it becomes imperative
then for the rest of us to rebut the
victimology narrative head-on it is not
enough to call for freedom of expression
that is if I may borrow a term a
relatively safe stance to take even some
liberals will back you up no if we're
going to restore sanity and civil
harmony we're gonna have to take on the
victim knowledge victimology narrative
directly and assert that racism and
oppression are not the predominant
characteristics of American society
today for all our historical sins and
they were real and terrible there has
never been a more tolerant opportunity
filled polity than our present one the
preservation of free
requires knowledge of and gratitude for
the extraordinary richness of Western
civilization with its patient
development of the rule of law the
scientific method and the concept of
individual rights until the majority of
universities returned to their proper
mission of passing on such institution
Hillsdale and the Kirby Center will be
ever more essential thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
questions yes sure you know this puts
the left in a very difficult position
it's it's are always the fal ready to
fact open the case that Asians don't
really count as students of color
because it turns out the the actual
operational definition of students of
color is students who are not
academically competitive since Asians
are whooping everybody else's ass out
there they don't count as students of
color nevertheless you know it's been
traditional on the part of the
proponents of racial preferences to play
it as a black-white issue and to play
off of of white guilt but it's been the
case for quite some time now that the
real victims of reverse discrimination
and racial preferences are Asians
because again they outscore everybody
they outscore Jews they outscore general
white White's in general and so when
schools are setting aside places so that
they can improve their diversity profile
with students that are basically it's
black and Hispanic it's always zero-sum
I mean they will try to persuade you
that preferences are not zero-sum that's
simply wrong I mean the the the the
number of spots that are available in
these selective schools are extremely
finite and so every student you admit
with a standard deviation or two below
the competitive norm is taking a place
away for somebody else and it's Asians
who are the most severely impacted by
this so what's been going on for many
years I actually think to my mind the
strongest criticism of racial
preferences which is really don't use
the term affirmative action that still
has sort of a hail
of good intentions and do-gooder ISM
what we're really talking about here are
simply preferences the best argument
against them as far as I'm concerned is
not the traditional constitutional one
however valid that is the constitutional
argument just says this is unfair it's
unconstitutional for a government body
or a government funded college to make
distinctions on the basis of race it
violates the Fourteenth Amendments Equal
Protection Clause and and that's how the
Supreme Court jurisprudence about racial
preferences has played out and continues
to be played out as far as I'm concerned
though the the stronger more persuasive
argument is that racial preferences do
not do their alleged beneficiaries any
good there's a theory that has been most
empirically fleshed out by a UCLA law
professor named Richard Sand are called
mismatched theory that holds that if you
bring students into an academic
environment for which they are not
academically competitive if their
academic preparedness is much below that
of their peers they're going to struggle
in their classes and they're not going
to learn as much and we see in law
schools every virtually every law school
employs huge racial preferences and the
black students in law school end up
overwhelmingly almost without exception
at the bottom half of their class and in
the bottom decile of their class it
blacks fail the bar bar at magnitudes
more times five or six times a higher
rate than whites because they haven't
learned as much because they're in an
environment that is pitched above their
heads
Richard sander has gotten as much data
as he can get to try and you want to
show the outcome of students that are
admitted with racial preferences
and those few blacks who are not who are
actually competitive with their school
to trace their course in school and
their bar passage rates he and other
proponents of the mismatch theory have
had to fight tooth and nail to get data
Harvard as you may know just app has put
up road block after road block to
releasing its admissions data it's
finally they finally got access to it
but with they had to be dragged through
several rounds of litigation and Richard
sander has asked the California Bar
Association to provide an amazed data on
its students who have taken the buckets
it has a very complete data set that has
students college GPAs their ell SATs
their law school GPA and their bar
scores and sadly a California appellate
court just denied his request on a
grounds that it was not justified under
California's public documents record law
which is very very tragic because the
data that does exist is has not been
refuted in improving that the mismatch
effect but more data the better but
these colleges are absolutely opaque and
you know if they were so confident that
racial been preferences would were good
for their recipients they wouldn't mind
sharing the data but they keep it under
complete lock and key yes
administration's to these preposterous
out cries and demands do you think it's
due to cowardice or do you think it's
that after 40 years of the whole
neo-marxist Graham Shand project shoved
through the universities that they
basically bought into that narrative as
well I think it's absolutely both I
think I think that they've they believe
it and it's just it's bizarre but we
know that human beings are capable of
believing very strange things that their
daily experience would seem to to
contradict because again for college
presidents to say I'm sending all my
faculty through implicit bias training
at enormous time expense on the theory
that they are discriminating against
qualified females and underrepresented
minorities in the hiring process is
contradicted every single day on a
college campus you cannot go to a
faculty search committee where that's
all that they talk about and I have
asked college administrators okay and
proponents of implicit bias theory if
this is so ubiquitous give me just one
name of a female faculty candidate or an
underrepresented minority who was not
given a job for which he or she was
superior quality or qualifications for
or I'll make it easy on you
we simply overlooked in a job search
because they weren't trying hard enough
they've ducked that question every time
so it's it just perverse but they I
think you're absolute they believe this
and because it makes them feel superior
to red state America that they think
that they are the places of of succor
and and safety for these ever-growing
victim groups who would otherwise be at
absolute risk of oppression out in the
great unwashed
Massa's you know who voted for Trump so
it's a combination but there's also
cowardice I mean there's people who I
think should know better and they just
you know there's nothing that's more
lethal to somebody's career today than
being called a racist and they don't
want to stand up to that yes since the
situation on many college campuses
deteriorating during a time when tuition
is skyrocketing do you see the higher
education bubble bursting where lots of
people just won't go to college or seek
out alternative forms of instruction
instead of four-year colleges and
universities it may start happening and
I know that Peter Thiel is thinking
about alternatives you know there was
the big hope for the MOOCs the massive
online what's the o second oh I don't
know something courses that didn't
really materialize you know that and
ironically it turns out that the most
challenged students are the ones who do
least well in online learning everybody
was sort of hoping that this would be a
way to help the underrepresented
minorities do it but they they need the
hands-on but frankly for status obsessed
post baby boomer parents that purport to
be so equity minded and yet are the most
fanatically you know social ladder
climbing people in the world they are
extremely eager to credential eyes their
children with the mark of an Amherst or
a Williams or a Stanford and that's
going to be a very hard thing to break
to to break that lock on credential
izing and you know there's a lot of
conservative libertarian voices that are
also saying don't go to college I'm a
mixed mind about that Brian Kaplan a
economist at George Mason University has
written a book called is it not the end
of education or does education Matt or
something and part of it I agree with he
says you know too far too many people
are going to college which is absolutely
true
and he addresses the paradox that
employers put such a high premium on a
college degree I mean the numbers are
sort of clear that you really do get a
very big boost in earnings with a
college degree but his point is but
these students they don't learn anything
so what the heck is an employer doing
paying an extra 20,000 30,000 50,000 and
salary but the book is also laced
through with utter contempt for learning
for its own sake and and Kaplan has
various disclaimers to these intends to
do that but it's it's unmistakeably
there and I'm not willing to go that far
I still I still to me the pursuit of
knowledge and the ability to study
literature and art and music is is the
highest privilege one can have and so I
think we need to still try and
reconstitute universities as places that
pass on the inheritance of Western
civilization yes it'd be great to see
and I imagine it's gotta be available
because the professorial staff is listed
online data on the trends on these
things because if you're going towards
equity then you've got to be hiring
underrepresented minorities at a
dramatic rate in order to in order to
shift what is already the institutional
norm so if men are white men are
over-represented then in order to shift
the direction you have to hire two or
three times as many under episode of
minorities as you are men right so do we
have data on that well no the I can tell
you that in some science fields like
computer engineering and economics
there's a slight creeping up of women
minorities that blacks and Hispanics cuz
again Asians they they're very
competitive it may be improving a little
bit but really the problem is the
pipeline and this is what it just drives
me nuts you know you can
talk about the composition of the
faculty without seeing who's getting
PhDs blacks have gotten been
concentrated black phd's concentrated
traditionally in education in 2016 there
were sixteen phd's granted to blacks in
computer engineering that's 1 percent of
the total so to expect that every
computer engineering department in the
country is going to have what 13 percent
blacks which is what their percentage of
the u.s. population is is simply absurd
and there's many fields physics you know
astrophysicists that have no black
graduates so they're just not available
but your question I mean it seems to
presuppose possibly that well there has
been a problem or that there's some
discrimination at work or you're just
asking empirically are they even
available to be hired they're not
available to be hired and I would also
say it's it doesn't matter the only
thing the only thing that matters is if
you're the most qualified person in your
field and if we have a lab that is
exclusively females that are all the
best nuclear engineers there are that's
great fine let it be but if they're also
all Asian males because they're the best
who cares the only thing that matters is
what they are capable of producing the
New York Times just this week had a
story about oh that the K through 12
teaching body is still largely white
females this means that black students
can't learn oh please you know I was
lucky to be in college in the 70s before
multiculturalism hit nobody thought to
complain that I was reading Chaucer
Spencer Milton and Wordsworth thank God
this is before feminism
I got to read the greatest writers
without anybody whining about what was
between their legs and it didn't matter
to me that the professor's who I revered
were males the idea that you can't learn
from somebody who's different from you
is ridiculous
but that's you know the idea and so now
you have UCLA requiring every faculty
applicant to make a statement about his
contributions to equity diversity and
inclusion so you have to ideally say
that I'm researching the problems of
underrepresented minorities or I have
the ability to attract and mentor
females and under-represent minorities
which is basically code in California
because you can't use explicit racial
preferences anymore - I am a female or
minority but you know I you have to
wonder whether Albert Einstein could be
hired at UC elated tomorrow because he's
not working on equity diversity and
inclusion he's working on the theory of
general relativity and I submit that
that's more important yes
[Music]
mom great schools in it not do you think
that a great school mace is a trade
school a community college or a
for-profit college
what's a trade school community colleges
are definitely getting hit by this
they're the last holdouts but they're
getting hit I was interviewed recently
by the Chronicle of Higher Education
about a community college in the San
Diego area of Southern California
MiraCosta that has just gone bonkers for
diversity it's all completely ethnic
studies hiring you know they've they've
destroyed whatever traditional
literature requirements they had so that
Chicano students only need to reach
Chicano authors as far as trade schools
if we're talking about like a degree in
auto mechanics that would really be
something if that gets it with gender
and race I don't know and the
for-profits
you know they've been on the news
recently with DeVos and the various
rules on accreditation I don't know
about them actually that that's an
interesting question
there for one thing I believe that they
are all commuter school I mean is there
any campuses there I think campuses tend
to sort of let this insanity fester and
stews so maybe a if it's all just like
correspondence course or something it
wouldn't be quite as bad yes why do you
think basketball courts and football
fields are exempt from diversity and
doesn't doubt the fact that there are
you know such 90% african-american
accentuate the stereotypes that they
don't want yeah because Americans think
sports are important academics not so
much ya know it's it's amazing but I
also think you know it's incredible that
we are push
females into combat units introducing
not only double standards and physical
qualifications but eros the most
destructive force in human existence is
eros it drives people insane we're
putting this into combat units but again
we will not force women on to the end
unto the National Football League
because football is important war less
so so you know people are quite capable
of holding two separate ideas and and
they're willing to have meritocracy when
it works in favor of the victim groups
just not when it it creates a bar that
for now does not lead to proportional
representation yes has the Trump
administration in the less than two
years that it's been an office done
anything to reverse the flow of funds or
have there been decisions from the
Justice Department trying to push back
against this stuff or are they just not
touching it they're proceeding with
deliberate speed I guess they've been
very good in some things as you may have
followed Betsy DeVos is is holding
notice and comment on the campus rape
due process problems they are they
joined the or had a statement of
interest in the Harvard lawsuit so they
have signaled that they are not going to
they withdrew a bunch of Obama era
guidances to colleges that basically
laid out the path for racial preferences
what they really need to do and this
would take a lot somebody that really
knows the regs the Code of Federal
Regulations is get rid of in its
entirety the disparate impact concept
wherever it exists this is the idea that
facially neutral standards are
nevertheless deemed discriminate
or if they have a disparate impact so if
you have a requirement that firefighters
know how to read at a twelfth grade
level if that requirement which is
facially neutral has the effect of
disqualifying blacks at a higher rate
than whites even though the intention of
the 12th grade reading rule was not to
exclude blacks it was to have people who
know how to read chemists you know the
chemicals that they are using that
that's nevertheless going to be deemed a
discriminatory violation so this
disparate impact idea is really at the
core of a lot of madness and that's
that's what Trump should get on but he
should also I mean it's really the
National Science Foundation is
completely out of control it's just it's
unbelievable what they're doing I cannot
tell you the nonsense that they're
funding they're funding gender studies
professors to study intersectionality in
the STEM fields it's madness so you know
NSF is a congressional creation whether
then that means that only Congress could
rein it in I'm not sure but there
certainly is a lot that can be done and
that remains to be done Jeff Sessions
obviously I mean he's a hero and I'm
just gonna say this is totally unrelated
I think Trump's treatment of him is
abysmal and grotesque and appalling he
has done so much in the area of law
enforcement and immigration enforcement
but you know it's a lot to also turn
turn to the Justice Department that's
also for Betsy DeVos to do yes
City and Oklahoma Wesleyan for standing
fast but the question is this looks like
a systemic change how do you go against
the systemic change and pull it back
this is so deep I know I know you're
like you know I agree with you and
probably the whole class here I mean the
audience's is right right with you and
what do we do I'm not I'm not in a
university setting so I have no I have
no influence there it's it's I have to
say I mean I know that as a speaker
there's sort of a mandate to be
optimistic and think we're gonna win I'm
by Constitution of a pessimist so
everything needs to be taken with a
grain of salt but I mean people like me
conservatives have been writing about
the universities for the past 30 years
using all of our rhetorical guns to mock
them and it does get worse and worse I
would just say again the more voices
that can be brought to bear to push back
on this idea of endemic racism and
sexism that's really what the problem is
the free speech problem that gets a lot
of attention is an epiphenomena of the
victimology as long as the victimology
is in place you're gonna have the
demands to silence speech on campus that
has deemed hate speech because it is
viewed as literally an existential
threat to these poor female and minority
students so you know people like me or
sessions anybody can invoke John Stuart
Mill til we're blue in the face and talk
about the need for open debate it's not
going to make a damn bit of difference
as long as the ideology of victimhood is
is the dominant one so all I can say is
if it comes up in conversation people
just have to start fighting back and say
we are not a racist society you know I
don't know a single mainstream
institution
that is not tying itself into knots to
be fair and to hire females and
minorities the other thing obviously is
that my lung I need to stop giving money
to their colleges there they're fueling
the Beast these endowments are huge and
you know it's an it's a it's a wonderful
instinct of giving back and generosity
but you have to do your due diligence
you wouldn't buy a stock without doing
due diligence don't send money into
these colleges unless you're really
confident that it's not going into the
victimology machine do you think it
could be considered deeper than
victimology maybe a movement a
socialistic movement perhaps somebody
jordan peterson sent around a video that
the some democratic committee has made
about their sort of message for america
and it's very much class politics not
identity politics and you know it's the
all of a sudden the rich took over and
they're gaming the system and ironically
there's a lot similar with steve
bannon's message which he made a film
about the 2008 financial meltdown
frankly at this point and it may be
because I was not really politically
aware during the Cold War I take class
politics over identity politics any day
at least there you know you have people
saying I'm a worker that's an
accomplishment being female is not an
accomplishment
I don't deserve credit for being female
it's not something to study being a
welder is being a chemist is that's
something you have accomplished so yes
class politics is bad and
America's you know the left wing of the
Democratic Party certainly likes to
flirt with socialism on the other hand
it likes its goodies you know and
nobody's gonna mess really with Silicon
Valley so it's it's really sort of
paying lip-service to the hip notion of
being sort of post neo-marxist but III
don't i think the identity politics are
a bigger poison in society so our
immigration system was changed
dramatically in nineteen seventy do you
see a tie-in between that and kind of
the diversity delusion today well it
could be I mean we certainly have a a
third world population here that was not
assimilated that you know it arrived and
and got we had already chicano studies
that were breeding this separatism so I
think it definitely makes it more
difficult you know Robert Putnam wrote a
groundbreaking work that said diversity
actually lessens social cohesion in
communities at lessens social trust he
then had to walk that back as he got so
attacked by the left because he's a
liberal but it's it's been borne out so
I think yeah we have were now at the
highest level of foreign-born population
since the turn of the nineteenth the
twentieth century but we're in a very
different environment without the
confidence in American values to demand
assimilation and instead we promote
separatism so I think yeah it's it's it
I think it's definitely related I'd have
to think about Europe I mean they're not
they're still much more committed
they're much less apologetic about
Western civilization than we are they
obviously have their Muslim problem but
French schools you learn French
literature and as far as I know there's
not a whole lot of apologizing going on
for it what German yeah they're state
possibly I mean the operas have been
destroyed that's for sure I mean the
opera productions they are just utterly
atrocious they trashed the greatest
works of on the musical stage I don't
know about the literature though you
think that that they're not reading Hina
and Kleist and Goethe I don't know could
be I mean German drums ironically
actually in the United States the German
departments traditionally were the
holdouts against French theory against
deconstruction and Jacques de he'd on
the 70s at Yale the Yale friend the
German department was seen as like so
backward because it was still reading
books instead of reading theory so
whether that reflects something true in
Germany I don't know but yes they have a
lot of they are easily manipulated
they've got their own guilt source so
that's true
[Applause]
you